the sauce to use a little bit of love
piece of salt the maple it actually
surprising really good hi everybody my
name is Jessica Lovato and I'm a Demi
chef of Disney's club 33 and today I
will be reviewing pasta
so I've been this industry for seven
years now and I will say I've had my
fair share of pasta and carbs and I
absolutely love it well being a college
student and whatnot
I did enjoy a lot of these and now I've
had my taste of fresh pasta and
absolutely loved it but that doesn't
mean that once in a while it's not good
to try these guys out
so first Lean Cuisines with Swedish
meatballs the box says cook for three
minutes on high stir it around I'm going
to put it back into the microwave for
another minute
and in 30 seconds you can see all that
steam gravy's noodles and Swedish
meatballs the gravy consistencies really
nice there's no breakage of the sauce
which is nice because when sauce breaks
it tends to look really nasty and it
just I mean you want food to look good
in order for you to eat it there are
nice flavor and now we're the top the
sauce to use a little bit of love piece
of salt the noodles aren't overly mushy
but they definitely are overdone it's
not messy either which is nice the sauce
isn't syrupy it's a nice consistency it
seems to sit on the noodles really well
I give it like give like a four because
seasoning is kind of lacking and the
noodles are overdone you may have to
consider when you're putting stuff in
there with sauces that the sauce is
going to continue to cook I think it's
okay so for our next pasta we've got
smart ones so this one does have cheese
it's gonna take a little bit longer in
the microwave system to be another three
minutes it's a tomato based sauce unlike
the gravy one from earlier so hopefully
this one doesn't overcook the noodles
and they still have a little bit of bite
and life in them
Oh my pastas ready so I'm gonna stir it
around you got Tomatoes got cheese
favorite ways just typical tomato sauce
with cheese so all in all smart ones
is it tomato and cheesy consistency nice
little bite to the noodles not too mushy
the cheese definitely hangs
well with the sauce yeah that's 105 just
because on noodles were a little bit
more enjoyable than the last next up we
have a me bowl tortellini pesto this one
calls for about a five minute and cook
and prep time I've got a pesto sauce
tortellinis and ricotta cheese so I'm
gonna give us a try out without burning
my mouth it was very very very hot and
it'll czar like chewy pretty chewy like
not in like a al dente kind of wave
almost like the dough really wet when
you meet it it doesn't orbed a lot of
this liquid and I feel like that's the
trouble with like frozen pastas is a
you're freezing on with these sauces so
it's like it's obviously gonna continue
to cook them but it could also overcook
them personally I think I would have
liked the toilet needs to like be filled
I don't think these are filled it's kind
of flat maybe a little bit more herbs a
little bit more basil just a little bit
of life just kind of like um like just
flattens out I think it kind of goes
with the first one and I'm gonna give
this guy a four just a teeny bit
disappointed ami next healthy choice so
this one is family favorite spaghetti
and meatballs what I want to look for it
here is the doneness of the meatballs
once they're done you know cooking in
the Marc Lieb I want to see the fight on
the spaghetti noodles I want to taste
how good the sauce is I'm looking for a
flavor we'll see you guys in four and a
half to five minutes traditional
spaghetti and meatballs oh my god I feel
really silly the sauce teams at the
bottom and you're pouring noodles and
meatballs in okay that's pretty cool
I'm not gonna lie and now like it makes
my sauce in my noodles it smells good
had some time to cool it down so I don't
burn my mouth I kind of rennes me I was
like the packaging I would get no
offense to this company but it's very
nostalgic it reminds me of when I would
get food back when I went to school like
in Boyle Heights and they give us like
these prepackaged
lunches and you could tell they just
steamed them out and you were just so
happy to have like a
we were meal that's what this kind of
reminds me of there isn't a lot of
flavor it could definitely use some
seasoning to it these noodles are
definitely really soft not too much of a
bite to them and let's see about a
meatball let me pull it actually
surprising really good I think it's like
their Savior here oh you got five of
them that's nice
really do make up for the lack of
seasoning in the sauce I would probably
give this because the meatball make a
five and a half out of ten on this one
the meatball really saved it I want to
give it a six I was a little impressed
with the bowl that was kind of cool okay
we'll be able to six the meatball on the
bowl we'll save it just a little bit
more love in the seasoning
I'll tell I can will they see for this
one okay up next on our list we have
family favorite Stouffer's this one is a
Stouffer's bowl with chicken bacon and
ranch with medium spice heat I'm Mexican
so I absolutely love spice so every
opportunity I have to go some chili
flake or some chili oil into my pasta
I'm there 100% this one's got a six
minute prep time six minutes later we
have pasta so this one is definitely
very cheesy got freaking you can see the
steam a little bit of mild chili inside
of it it smells really good what I'm
noticing right away it's very very
cheese heavy like when I stirred it
around I almost had to look for the
pasta because it just got completely
lost in the sauce
your teachers break through right away
so when you're stirring these things
around per instructions be careful
because you don't want to go and break
apart your pasta let's try a piece of
chicken chickens okay
it's cooked all the way through which is
like number one very important I believe
that what they did here is relied a lot
more on the sauce to be its flavor
you've got a lot of cheese going on in
here and if you're into these super
cheesy pastas by all means you're really
gonna enjoy this one but everything kind
of just gets lost you know it's okay I
probably give it I give it a six just
because the sauce and the cheese really
does save it for the flavoring the
chicken could have used somewhere
flavoring when the noodles are well
overcooked so yeah I give it a solid 6
this is the Stouffer's lasagna and this
is the family size one and you can do it
in your oven or you can do it in your
microwave it's really just a matter of
preference takes about 34 minutes from
quick and prep times this is our
finished product so as you can see it's
cooked a little bit extra on the sides
you have some hardened cheese here
that's because you have to cook about
the lid on top of it so I can fully cook
all the way through
you've got lasagna the meat sauce and of
course we've got cheese the inside herbs
seasoned tomato sauce and real real
mozzarella cheese
so let's go ahead and see how we go this
piece
ha very hot not terrible at all yeah I
could probably this the noodles are
cooked well there's a lot of cheese
I like the ratio of meat in there even
in that small bite that I got I got a
really good amount of meat flavor-wise I
think it's good like you know for
lasagna and you've got the tomato flavor
I do taste the herbs you do get the
cheesy stringiness inside of it and the
meat is seasoned well you know as well I
can actually see like bits of it and I
can taste the urban side of it and the
noodles definitely hold up the sauce I
do see the cheese on the inside which is
really nice as well I think I could get
this one won't you listen to solid eight
yeah it just took for such a small
package it it take quite a while to cook
what I would recommend when doing
something this large and you're trying
to feed your family at a fast time take
it out ahead of time let it thaw all I
know I think these are all really good
then you have different flavor profiles
for sure and it's always nice to go back
and try the frozen meals and then go
ahead and taste the fresh herb regions
of these things and see the differences
for yourself
[Music]
you